our world is extraordinarily complicated
so in physics we're going to have to
make simplifications
even things in our world that seem
simple are extraordinarily complicated
so consider a basketball
seems simple enough but it's composed of
an extraordinarily
large number of air molecules bouncing
around inside
colliding with the outside leather and
rubber membrane which
itself is composed of an extraordinarily
large number of atoms and molecules all
bonded together
holding on tight trying to prevent
themselves from being ripped apart and
exploded
by the pressure inside so do we have to
keep track of
every atom and molecule in this ball to
include it in a physics problem
typically not nor would we ever really
want to i mean we can't keep track of
all that info
not yet nor would you want to for most
scenarios so
for instance if you were an astronaut
you went to the moon you took your
basketball
and you were going to drop it if all you
wanted to know was how long it's going
to take for this ball to strike the
lunar surface below
you don't need to know about the ideal
gas law you don't need to know about the
structural integrity
of the rubber leather membrane you could
solve this by treating the basketball as
if there was no internal structure
whatsoever
like you were dropping a rock that had
no interesting
internal structure whatsoever so in
physics
the good news is we could typically get
away with making a lot of
simplifications and ignoring
the internal structure if it isn't
relevant to the problem that we're
asking
sometimes it will be relevant though so
here was a case where it wasn't relevant
the internal structure wasn't relevant
so we could ignore that internal
structure but other questions like if
you're an astronaut
i mean if i was an astronaut and i was
bringing my basketball to the moon i'd
be like wait a minute
there's no atmosphere on the moon that
means there's no pressure pushing
in from the outside that means all this
air pressure's still pushing out from
the inside
is my basketball just to explode i'd
want to know this before i brought it
out there i want to carry a
little bomb out that's going to like
blow up in my face and i don't want to
lose a basketball
if you wanted to know if your basketball
was going to explode okay now it does
depend that question
does depend on the internal structure
depends on the pressure inside which is
fundamentally related to
the force of the collisions between
these air molecules
and the rubber membrane and then it
depends also on
well how strong are the bonds between
these rubber membrane and leather
molecules
how much force can they withstand before
they burst
for that question you would have to
consider the internal structure
so in some questions you get to ignore
the internal structure
and other questions you don't it's just
context and question dependent
and in physics we have terminology to
sort of sort this out and the
terminology we use is
the idea of a system or the idea of an
object so the idea of a system
is just a collection of objects that's
the definition of a system
in physics but that begs the question
well what do we mean by an object
by an object we mean anything that you
could treat as if
it had no internal structure we don't
mean that objects have no internal
structure
they typically do the only things that
don't
truly have an internal structure as far
as we know are truly fundamental
particles like electrons or
neutrinos these fundamental particles
and particle physics that
as far as we know have no internal
structure so unless you're doing
particle physics
you probably don't have a true object
but you can treat things like an object
we can treat this basketball like an
object
that is to say we can act as if it has
no internal structure
if that internal structure isn't
relevant to the problem so
to make this a little more meaningful
just imagine another example say you
collide two objects
uh say you collide a putty here
let's say this is three kilogram object
and it comes in with a certain speed and
it collides with a
5 kilogram object if all you want to
know is when they stick together
say these stick together and move off
with some common speed
if all you want to know is what is that
common speed that they move off with
after they stick together
notice what you don't need to know i
don't need to tell you that this was
made out of
gold here or that this one was made out
of copper
as long as you know the masses and that
they stick together physics will let you
solve for how fast
they'll move off with a common speed
afterward if you tell me that they stick
together
so that's all you want to know doesn't
matter what the internal structure is
however for other questions if you
wanted to know if this was going to set
off some
nuclear explosion okay well then
it really is going to matter if these
are made out of gold
made out of copper made out of clay or
if they're made out of
uranium so to speak so for that question
you do need to know about the internal
structure
so the idea of a system an idea of an
object is an important one in physics
and it's not just important conceptually
or abstractly
it can actually help you in problem
solving so let me show you a more like
tangible
example of where this might help you in
solving a problem you might encounter
in your physics courses so let's say
they're two boxes
and they're just too big and unwieldy to
handle so you're gonna push them across
the floor
they're not heavy they're just like
shaped weird let's say and let's say the
floor has been newly waxed
so it's real slick against these boxes
which are also slick and there's
negligible friction you could ignore the
friction between the boxes and the floor
so let's say you come up and you're
going to push on these things push them
into the corner of some warehouse you're
working in the warehouse here
earn and you pay for the day and you're
gonna go push these over here and you're
gonna exert
let's just say nine newtons of force on
this one kilogram box and then that
pushes into the two kilogram box and
they move off to the right
so can we treat this system of boxes as
if it were a single object
well like we said it's question
dependent if the question we want to ask
is what's the acceleration of these
boxes as they slide to the right
well they're going to move at the same
rate because as you push on this one
kilogram box
that one kilogram box pushes on the two
kilogram box they're gonna move together
as i keep pushing with nine newtons uh
the velocity of both of these boxes are
gonna be the same to the right
and the acceleration of the boxes are
gonna be the same to the right they're
never gonna come separated
what that means is the fact that there
were two boxes didn't matter i can treat
this
system of two boxes as if it were a
single three kilogram box
i don't even need to know that they were
actually a division here because they're
never going to become separated
for this question that i'm asking here
so i could treat this whole system
as if it were just one big three
kilogram object
and this is an important idea the
properties of a system
like the mass of the system are
determined by
the properties of the objects in that
system so i put a 3 here and this is
legal this is allowed
the properties of this total mass of my
system is determined by the mass of the
individual objects in my system so you
really can just add up these masses to
determine
the total mass of the system that you're
going to be treating as a single
object and now that i get to treat this
as a single object i'm in luck
i can use newton's second law the
acceleration is going to equal the net
force over the mass we'll do this
for the horizontal direction i'm just
going to put a mass of three
i could ignore the fact that this was a
one and a two
and the total mass of my system is going
to be three kilograms
and the only force on my system that i'm
treating as an object here is the nine
newton force i could ignore
in other words i can ignore the internal
forces between these boxes
i don't care about the one pushing on
the two or the two pushing on the one
i'm treating the system like an object
and i'm ignoring that internal structure
that makes this problem really easy when
i solve for the acceleration i just get
three
meters per second squared so for this
question
i could treat this system as a single
object what question would i not be able
to treat this system as a single object
for well if i wanted to know let's say
the question was
with how much force does the one
kilogram box exert on the two kilogram
box
and you might think oh it's just nine
but it isn't so stay tuned hold on
it's counterintuitive i know but the the
main idea i'm trying to stress here is
that
this force on two by one is
fundamentally a question about an
internal force
so if the question you're asking is
about the internal structure
clearly you're not allowed to ignore the
internal structure so for this question
we cannot
treat this system of two boxes as if it
were a single mass
we'll have to focus on the internal
structure so again consider this a one
and a two separate boxes and we'll do
the same formula acceleration is going
to equal
the net force over the mass but this
time we do have to focus on a single
mass
so we'll focus just on the two kilogram
mass
the only horizontal force on this two
kilogram mass if this really is
frictionless
is this force that we want to find the
force onto by one
and that's the only force that's exerted
on the two kilogram mass
this nine newtons is exerted directly on
the one so it's not directly exerted on
the two we don't draw that up here we
don't include that here these are only
forces directly on the two
and then we'd have to put the
acceleration of the two kilogram mass
but we already found that
this three was the acceleration of the
one the two and the entire system
everything was accelerating at the same
rate so i put my three
meters per second squared here and i
find out that the force
exerted on the two by the one is
6 newtons so it's not as big and this
isn't surprising
it takes more newtons from the left here
this 9 newtons to accelerate the entire
system of 3 kilograms
than it does to just accelerate the 2
kilogram mass over here so the fact that
this force is accelerating less mass
means it doesn't have to be as big but
the key idea is that to find that we
could not treat
to find this force here we could not
treat this entire system
as a single mass so recapping
if the question being asked does not
depend on the internal structure
you can simplify your life by treating
that structure and that system as if it
were a single object
in which case the properties of that
will be determined by the properties of
the objects in that system
but if the question being asked does
depend on the internal structure
then you cannot treat that system as a
single object you will have to focus
on the internal structure